[Music]
on this Sunday night the Russian
president's Defiance condemnation over
Vladimir Putin's top secret trip deep
inside war-torn Ukraine
plus the plans show a support by Putin's
biggest Ally Mega prison criticism The
increased intake as El Salvador extends
its state of emergency
the ripple effect of kindness for
refugees did this year changed all of
our life how a note between two moms
with very different lives helped change
others
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with the bold and
defiant move by the Russian president
deep inside Russian occupied territory
in war-torn Ukraine for the very first
time since his full-scale invasion
under the cover of Darkness Vladimir
Putin drove through the streets of
maryupal the city that saw the worst
atrocities Russian forces in Ukraine are
accused of to date yesterday Putin
traveled to Crimea to Mark the ninth
anniversary of the Black Sea Region's
annexation from Ukraine these visits are
the closest Putin has ever been to the
front lines of this war and come just
days after the international criminal
court issued a warrant for his arrest
and as Redmond Shannon reports hours
ahead of his most important allies visit
to Moscow
Vladimir Putin going for a drive around
mariu ball a city obliterated by his
2022 invasion of Ukraine the Russian
media footage also shows Putin meeting
people purported to be construction
workers at a new residential development
Ukraine has compared the visit to that
of a criminal returning to the scene of
his crime
the U.N estimates 90 percent of the
buildings in the port city were damaged
last year Ukraine says 20 000 civilians
were killed an Associated Press analysis
estimated 600 Alone died when this
theater used as a bomb shelter was hit
on Saturday Russian TV showed Putin in
crimea's largest city the region
occupied exactly nine years ago in
Russia's first invasion of Ukraine the
two visits come in the days after the
international criminal court issued an
arrest warrant for Putin on charges of
unlawful deportation of Ukrainian
children and as his forces continue the
brutal battle for the small city of
bakmut what you tried to do if your
Putin is those who are still with you
you try to give the image which says
look there's you know we still have this
quote Success and at least part of
Ukraine Putin will also want to put on a
positive image ahead of Monday's visit
to Moscow of China's Xi Jinping the two
countries have a so-called No Limits
partnership but Beijing has stopped
short of supplying heavy weapons to
Putin until China does that I think you
can say that they are balancing China is
taking more of a global diplomatic role
we saw this when they brokered the Saudi
Iranian resumption of relation only a
few days ago
the number one point on China's proposed
peace plan is that territorial Integrity
be respected but it doesn't demand that
Russia's troops withdrawal from Ukraine
ji's words in Moscow will be closely
watched as will his actions afterwards
it has been reported that he will follow
the visit with a phone call to Ukraine's
Vladimir zielinski Redmond Shannon
Global News London as the Ukraine war
rages on another batch of Canadian
battle tanks have been prepped and are
now on the way to the front lines
new Defense Force video uploaded to
social media shows a handful of leopard
two tanks being loaded onto a plane
Bound for Europe
Ottawa has announced it will donate
eight leopard two tanks to help Kiev the
Trudeau government has also pledged to
send about 8 000 rounds of artillery
ammunition and 12 air defense missiles
all part of a one billion dollar
Canadian commitment to Ukraine
in Quebec the number of missing from
that apartment fire in Old Montreal is
now up to at least seven people
today Crews began slowly dismantling the
building as investigators begin the
painstaking process of sifting through
the charred wreckage believing more
victims are likely buried under the
debris an arson team is investigating
but has been unable to take a closer
look because of potentially unsafe
conditions
to Ottawa now as the opposition ramps up
pressure on the government over alleged
foreign interference in our elections
the conservatives are also putting the
country's Health Care problems back in
the spotlight at a press conference
today leader Pierre pauliev proposed a
new policy to resolve Staffing shortages
and to help lessen the burden on
overwhelmed health care workers across
the country our Mackenzie gray joins us
from Ottawa with more Mackenzie
Healthcare is likely going to play a
large role in the next election so
what's this new proposal about
well if our appear polyam spends a lot
of time saying Canada is broken and at
the top of his list is the health care
System but today he made a where policy
proposal to try and fix it and let's go
through it he's calling for a blue seal
national accreditation program to let
doctors nurses and other Health Care
Professionals work in whatever Province
they want and it sounds like a simple
solution but right now in a number of
provinces the only way you can work in
them is if you're accredited to work in
that Province even if you're a graduate
of a Canadian institution now the only
way the polyet plan will work if he gets
the provinces on board and he says he's
confident they'll be able to come to an
agreement our Blue Seal for professions
will be strictly voluntary and the
provinces will have an incentive to join
and Mackenzie poliev was asked about a
big vote in the House of Commons next
week on Chinese electoral interference
what's a conservative strategy on this
yeah far the poly of play on this one is
to try and get Katie Telford the prime
minister's Chief of Staff to testify at
the house Ethics Committee about what
she knows about Chinese electoral
interference we call on the prime
minister to stop the cover-up if he's
got nothing to hide why doesn't he allow
his chief of staff to come and tell the
truth and the reason the conservative is
opted for a full house vote is because
the Liberals have been filibustering for
nearly 24 hours at another house
committee to avoid having Telfer to
speak but hearing from Miss Telford
could shed some more light on what the
prime minister's office knew about the
alleged interference Justin Trudeau's
former National Security adviser dick
Fadden has said that the Prime Minister
chief of staff is someone who's normally
made aware of serious National Security
matters more often than not unless it's
an extraordinarily detailed and
sensitive material a number of people
from pmo would sit in I think in most
instances the chief of staff would sit
in in any event and it's not just the
conservatives that want her to testify
pharah the NDP and block are also on
side with their motion so it appears the
opposition parties do have the votes to
compel Telford to speak we'll be
watching what happens next week
Mackenzie Grant Ottawa thank you
Health Canada has issued more warnings
this month about the health risks linked
to unauthorized skin lightening products
now here's the thing it's not the first
time these creams and toners by
Philippine brand brilliant skin
Essentials have been pulled from the
shelves Nito Garcia looks at why the
products keep returning despite the
potentially toxic ingredients inside
advertising The Wider your skin the
beautiful you are when Ontario resident
Jenny torretta was a teenager growing up
in the Philippines she says she felt
pressured to lighten her skin she no
longer uses them but for nearly 10 years
to Retta says she spent thousands on
whitening products like soaps lotions
pills and injections it's still very
rampant in the Philippines the whitening
products promoting Global racism and
colorism in the west many skin care
Giants have rebranded promising to stop
using terms like whitening and fairness
Amina miray who's been researching the
industry for more than two decades is
calling for explicit legislation in
Canada
cosmetic promotion cosmetic marketing of
products that actually explicitly say
it lightens or whiten the skin there is
no legal statue for that in health
Canada's latest warning various Health
Products promoted for lightening skin
sold in Alberta by Philippine brand
brilliant skin Essentials were removed
from the warehouse location and from
online sale due to potentially dangerous
ingredients and ingredients not listed
on the label the two agents in question
are Tretinoin cream as well as
hydroquino so when these people are
trying to bleach their face and they're
using copious amount of tretinoin and in
a worst case scenario if they become
pregnant and they continue to use those
agents they can harm their penis there
have been multiple Health Canada
advisories for the brand since January
some industry experts say it's because
the massive skin whitening industry has
developed a new and clever niche in
marketing the products we're talking
about hundreds of billions of dollars of
Global Market that has no legal statue
whatsoever to write us as her message is
to encourage people to embrace their
individual and natural beauty the way
she wishes she had
Global News
a shotgun Bank merger was announced this
afternoon in Europe to avoid further
Market turmoil in global banking Swiss
bank UBS has agreed to buy smaller rival
credit Suites for 4.4 billion dollars
Canadian the Swiss banking marriage
follows efforts in Europe and the United
States to support the sector since the
collapse of three U.S banks last week
spring break beaches threatened by a
giant blob of seaweed coming up where it
will hit and when
Beach friends in Florida could be
smothered by a toxic blob of seaweed
taking aim at the Gulf of Mexico The
Blob is known as the Great Atlantic
sargassum belt and is twice the width
that the entire United States sargassum
isn't just unsightly for beachgoers it
can wreak havoc on ecosystems and it can
even be harmful to humans
there are no shortage of ways to
describe how terrible of a disease
dementia can be the risk is especially
more precarious for women as data shows
they're more likely to be affected than
men but while people may not think too
much can be done to prevent it there's
the Canadian non-profit that's focused
on women's brain health and it's
launched a new app aimed at giving them
a better Fighting Chance Catherine Ward
explains
is the awareness that I I have Now 46
year old Kathy colitis is a busy mom to
two young boys recently she has become
more conscious of taking care of herself
and specifically her brain I think it
just hits home that it is a very strong
possibility that you know something
could happen to me as a woman especially
in knowing what the stats are
colitis is referring to the likelihood
of dementia and Alzheimer's almost 70
percent of Alzheimer's sufferers are
women and women suffer from other brain
aging diseases like stress anxiety
depression twice as much as men experts
with women's brain health initiatives
say the damage often occurs long before
people realize what's happening most
people with late onset of Alzheimer's
disease they tend to show symptoms you
know in their 70s and 80s sometimes
their 90s but what the science is now
showing is that by the time symptoms
occur it's likely that the damages
happen 20 to 25 years prior in December
the organization launched a new brain
fit app to help women focus on setting
goals and making choices we've already
had over 10 000 downloads which for an
app like this is outstanding the app has
people choose goals or habits in
different areas related to brain health
then it tracks the progress it will send
you a little reminder and then you know
you check off that you drank the the
water that you said you were going to
there are also support tools including
videos and articles colitis says for her
the motivation to keep going is twofold
with the long-term results top of mind
my goal is to to build on what I've
started and to maintain it because I
want to be a healthy mom for my kids the
emotional toll on society is huge on the
community and the financial costs to the
Health Care system is going to just
swamp it so we need to do whatever we
can Catherine Ward Global News Toronto
[Music]
I had more inmates flood El Salvador's
Mega prison the widespread support in
the country and the mountain criticism
from the outside
in Ecuador and Peru at least 15 people
are dead after a magnitude 6.8
earthquake shook both countries this
weekend search and rescue efforts are
underway for survivors trapped under the
rubble of collapsed homes many of which
did not meet building standards for the
Quake prone country according to
officials there is no threat of the
disaster being followed by a tsunami
despite the Tremors hitting near
Ecuador's Coast
in El Salvador the population of the
country's new Mega prison is growing a
second group of 2 000 inmates were
transferred to the facility this week
it's built to house 40 000 prisoners as
Mike Armstrong explains while the
Salvadorian government insists the
compound is needed for its war on gangs
critics say the Crackdown comes with a
cost
they are images the Salvadoran
government wants seen the transfer of
inmates from one prison to a new one its
official name is secot the Spanish
abbreviation for terrorism confinement
Center the transfer was filmed and
released by the government along with a
message from the Justice Minister
because the men terrorist gang leaders
and says they'll never be back on the
streets
facility is spread over 410 Acres about
80 kilometers from the capital it has
eight cell blocks each with 50 cells
they'll be cramped each cell is set to
house 100 inmates with only 80 bunks and
just two sinks and two toilets the
president of neighboring Colombia said
earlier this month the images of the
prison gave him chills and called it a
concentration campus
now El Salvador insists it needed the
new space for its Crackdown on crime
after 87 people were killed in gang
violence in just a few days in March of
last year the government declared a
state of emergency it suspended some
rights including the right to a lawyer
and increased the amount of time people
can be held without being charged over
the last year more than 65 000 people
have been rounded up the government is
set to extend the anti-gang measures and
the head of the National Police says
it's needed to continue the fight
human rights groups say hundreds of
innocent people have been swept up and
dozens have died in police custody one
local group says it's documented more
than 3 300 human rights abuses
now that doesn't mean the measures
haven't been popular murders in 2022
dropped 57 percent from the year before
walls that would have been covered in
gang markings are being painted over a
poll last month pegged support for the
state of emergency at 92 percent
it's more security this mechanic says I
can walk with my young children before I
didn't even take them out El Salvador
already led the world in the number of
prisoners per capita the new facility is
pushing it further into the lead now has
an estimated two percent of its entire
population behind bars like Armstrong
Global News
[Music]
next how a note from one mom to another
started a friendship and a cycle of
kindness for Ukrainian refugees
[Music]
as the war in Ukraine rages on the
number of applications from ukrainians
wanting to come here to Canada has now
surpassed nine hundred thousand and
there is still a great need for host
families one mom in Calgary and her
family have managed to help over 30
Ukrainian newcomer families in the past
year and those newcomers have kept the
kindness going Carolyn Curry de Castillo
reports
on the day the war started and kucharaba
and her husband and three kids were away
from their home in nipro just a
week-long trip to the mountains they had
no idea they would not come home again
if you don't have stuff we don't have
clothes we don't have stuff because we
are going to Mountain we think only one
week and we never come back they stayed
in the Czech Republic for three months
before coming to Calgary where they
didn't know anyone Anne's daughter came
home from school one day with a note
from a mom named Tammy who wanted to
help she started help for us she started
singing she was every sinful necessary
for newcomer for people from youth
family here Tammy Brigadier found
there's a lot of support you can give
without being a host family she's been
able to collect donations and help with
documents and driving she uses her
connections to assist newcomers navigate
new surroundings and has helped host
Gatherings that bring ukrainians and
Canadians together something that seems
relatively small on our end will have a
massive impact like they have a bit of a
running chance now of of making it and
says the support she got from Tammy and
her family's been a huge help her
English is so good now that she works at
a local registry's office where she
assists other new arrivals get their
documents I am explaining that also many
people even don't understand how
right Calgary I help and I feel useful
now Tammy has helped over 30 families
now she says it's a lot of work but
rewarding I think that it will be a
lifelong lesson for my kids to to see
um
the Ripple effects of being kind and
compassionate I've had an opportunity to
meet all of these really wonderful
people I just miss for my mama and says
she worries for her mom back in nepro
but knowing her kids are safe and
surrounded by people who care makes all
the difference if you think about this
year change all of our life
but be happy here now Carolyn Curry de
Castillo Global News
kindness of strangers that's global
national for this Sunday night I'm Farah
Nasser on behalf of our whole crew I
want to thank you so much for spending
part of your Sunday evening with us
tonight's your candidate is Banff
Alberta and we love seeing your Canada
so please email us your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com Donna
we'll be back with you tomorrow until
next time take care of yourselves and
take care of each other good night
thank you